COLUMBUS, FEELING PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT ITSELF AFTER THE 8 GAME -
COMES GIVE UP ON IT.
HAD THE CHANCE EARLY ON.
THEY STUCK M BENNETT.
TAKEN AWAY BY CROWLELE
-- WAS SET BACK
YOU PROBABLY WON'T SURPASS
BEING THE LEAD AFTER TONIGHT.
RIGHT THROUGH 50 POINTS WHEN
YOU GET A THE
RIGHT POSITION.
YOU SEE, HE STAYS WITH IT.
BENNETT GETS IT BACK TO HIS
GOOD BUDDY. DOUG FREE.
NYQUIST IS A
THEY SCORE.
THING, THEY RULE OUT THE SHOT
WITH A POWER-PLAY GOAL. HEADED
THE PUCK WAS BEHIND THE N, PANT
THEY'VE GOT
FLORIDA PANTHERS.
GOING, YOU SEE INTO 1. --  HORN
QUIST THERE.
HE SLIDES IT, THEN COMES BACK
TO WEAKER HEAR.
YOU CAN SEE THE E THE
LAST 8 GAMES.
COLUMBUS COMES BACK.
JENNER
IT WAS A
TRYING THE SHOOTING HIGH.